[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000. as always my name is caleb
denby and tonight i will be your driver
on this journey
and i wanted to take you through some
games that i actually just played last
weekend at the mid-america open
tournament here in clayton in st louis
actually
um it's one of the bigger
open tournaments they have in st louis
every year that's actually not at the
trust club so
fun stuff i had a pretty good tournament
i gained some rating points and wanted
enough money to pay for my entry fee and
not much else
but i played some interesting games and
i wanted to show them here here tonight
and what i wanted to start with is i
think what the title of the the youtube
video might be it's about the old indian
defense so
in my second round i was playing someone
by the name of timothy
rottermacher rotter maker something like
that
and he played the old indian defense
against me and it had been a while since
i had seen this opening so i wanted to
talk a little bit about it uh why it's
not so popular these days and how it
sort of relates to other openings and
how i managed to get a pretty good
position and end up winning this game so
we'll jump into it so has anybody heard
of the old indian defense before you
know anything about this one yeah justin
yeah
uh so you described the
either b6 going for like a queen's
indian or g6 bishop b7 going for a
king's indian the old indian
way different so basically the best way
i can describe it is it's like a king's
indian but black's going to put this
bishop on e7 instead of g7 so the game
started with d4 black plays d6
now if you're an e4 player and you like
playing against the pierce you could
play e4 here and transpose i'm not one
of those kinds of people so i play
knight f3
and the goal is to stop e5 here you play
c4
now the problem is e5 might actually
turn out to be a pretty good move black
is pretty happy about any end game going
on here it's going to go c6 king c7 and
white would maybe rather not have this
pawn all the way out on c4
so that's why i play knight f3
preventing e5
black plays knight f6 now i'm not
worried about playing c4 anymore
um black goes knight b to d7 i just
continue developing
we get e5 by black i play e4
and it's not too late here for black to
sort of change courses and go for a more
normal king's indian setup with knight b
d7 on the board but instead he does play
this move bishop to e7 so
what's going on here why would black
ever you know put this bishop on this
slightly weird looking square
well there are i think some advantages
to it although we're not going to really
see them in in this game
for one a lot of the time when you put
this bishop over here
let's just play some moves let's say
white was interested in playing one of
the exchange variations just for example
and black took back with the pawn just
for example um this bishop is going to
look pretty dumb on g7 for for most of
this game here you know why why is this
bishop here it's just staring at its own
pawn
you might be able to claim that some
it's indirectly supporting d4 and that's
going to matter if black can get a
knight here but in general you know this
bishop is sort of stuck behind its own
pawn
so you can imagine that if we did the
exact same line
let's say c6 here
and takes takes
now this bishop is looking a little bit
more normal on e7 it's controlling all
of these squares it's helping to support
something like knight to c5 to e6 for
example
and maybe this bishop is a little bit
better placed at least that's kind of my
understanding of why this bishop might
belong here
so that's that's one of the reasons
another reason is maybe black isn't so
happy learning all of the king's indian
theory and he wants to play something
offbeat and this is one way to try to
get your opponent out of that that more
normal theory
um that being said you know i just stuck
to the the normal ideas here i did play
bishop e2 black did castle and as did i
and black did play this move c6 so
uh the question here is you know i've
sort of mentioned that i'm not really
loving this idea of taking on e5 right
away i'm not really loving opening up
this bishop
um and
maybe i can talk about that a little bit
more but with that in mind uh just take
my word for it you don't really want to
take on here and we'll i'll look into it
a little bit more but
with that being said what what do you
want to do if you don't want to take on
e5 here what constructive things can you
do to improve your position
hello to chess bunzo in the youtube chat
by the way thanks for joining
how can we keep
developing our pieces
and improving the position
yeah so this dark square bishop is um i
agree it's sort of our last piece that
we want to develop so you suggested
maybe the g5 square
and it's it's a reasonable square i
think bishop g5 does happen in this
opening sometimes
um and then in the youtube chat chess
bunzo actually mentioned the e3 square
so which of these squares kind of looks
better on the surface
just surface level which one would you
sort of rather have
probably e3 right um but
what happens if you try to play bishop
e3 right away
something bad might happen to you
this is a really useful idea to know in
these positions
so this bishop looks pretty nice right
it's controlling all of these squares
and we're anticipating that something
might happen to this pawn maybe black
will take our pawn maybe we'll take
black's pawn maybe we'll push d5 but
either way this diagonal is going to
open up as well so there's a beautiful
bishop here
but black can harass it
so
yeah knight g4
black's going to be able to jump out
with the knight
um and white is not at all going to be
happy if knight takes e3
uh lands on the board
so i like this idea of bishop e3 and i
don't like this idea of bishop g5 quite
as much i think it's perfectly fine and
if i cheat first oh don't look at that
um
okay don't look at that either if i
cheat for a second and i go to a
database
yeah bishop g5 has been played before
with like some mixed results but it's a
very reasonable move now
i didn't really want to go for it in the
game because
something about the old indian defense
and really the king's indian is always
that white has more space in the center
right so when you have more space
it's usually a good idea to leave as
many pieces on the board as possible you
don't really want to be trading pieces
when you have more space
and we'll see why in a moment in this
game but in general the idea is
if you don't have as much space and you
have all your pieces left they're going
to start to get in each other's way you
just don't have enough squares to find a
good spot for all of your pieces
and in the meanwhile white has enough
space to find good squares for all the
pieces and we'll see that sort of arise
later on
um and so with bishop g5 the thing that
you might run into is simply h6
and i don't think you're really happy
giving this bishop away here um and
maybe
one of your ideas is to just sort of try
to reroute the the bishop back to g3
um let's say something like queen c2
knight h5 and in the only game where
this has been played white did actually
take on e7 uh maybe you can justify
trying to bring this back to g3 and put
pressure on on e5 but i'm not really
convinced so i wasn't in love with this
idea
of bringing this bishop out to g5 for
those kinds of reasons i want to leave
pieces on the board i'm going to make my
opponent's life difficult and i felt
like bishop g5 might lead to this bishop
just getting traded off
so
putting that all together
not in love with bishop g5 i do really
like this e3 square but knight g4 is a
problem so with all of that in mind what
move
now might come to mind for white
focusing on this bishop e3 idea
h3
it's exactly right we just want to play
h3
prevent this knight from coming to g4
and we'll take our time we'll take our
time with things and play bishop e3 soon
um that being said i didn't do that yet
um i actually chose to play queen c2
first which i think is a pretty good
idea
so what's the point of queen c2 well i
actually want to bring this rook over to
the d file
and i did these things first before
playing bishop to e3 so
uh
that's something else that you can do
with this dark square bishop is sort of
wait a couple moves let black make a
couple more decisions as long as you
have useful moves to play and then you
can play something like like h3
so i did go queen c2 first my opponent
played queen to c7 which is all very
normal for this opening he wants to
support his pawn
riff to d1 rip to e8
and now we are going to see this h3 idea
um and i had known just from memory that
this queen c2 rook d1 idea was was
pretty decent here uh but then after
this i was sort of playing out of book i
didn't know any theory i i mean i had
some idea of the plans and uh came up
with h3 on my own turns out it's one of
the best moves
so h3 played in the game
uh now i believe my opponent has sort of
run out of things to do
which is something that kind of happens
in this opening if uh white is very very
patient so what black is really like
hoping and praying for here is that uh
white gets impatient white takes on e5
uh which allows black now to play for
these kinds of plants it gives black the
c5 square or black play or white plays
something like d5 which again is going
to open up the game a little bit for
black it's going to give up some of
these dark squares knight c5 again is
going to be an idea maybe a5 first then
knight c5
and black again is is going to be
playing with
with ideas in the center
but if white does something like h3 like
i did in the game
yes this move looks very slow but
because black just doesn't have enough
space black is running out of useful
things to do like you can try to
reorganize your pieces but you're never
really going to have enough squares
so black did find one more useful move
he played this move a5 which is just a
generally good move it takes space on
the queen side it helps prepare for a
knight c5 again if if white gets
impatient here
um
knight to c5 in this position and black
might be doing well
um
and i promised i would talk a little bit
more about why i didn't want to take on
e5 so i guess i'll do that now
so
after takes on e5 and takes on e5 you
might still think that white has more
space in the center right because we
have our pawn on c4 versus this pawn on
c6 we have good control over d5
it looks like we have more space but
actually this structure really heavily
favors uh the player with the black
pieces
uh now does anybody know why why is
black doing well here in this structure
it has to do with these two pawns this
is the big difference in the structure
what's
up because black threatens b5
so not really b5 it's actually just
about these these central squares so
uh white
is yes controlling um
controlling the d5 square very well uh
but black is also actually countering
this square so it's difficult to imagine
how white is going to play a move like
knight to d5
and to your point also b5 b5 is defended
not so much black trying to push on this
side but just preventing white from
advancing forward
uh meanwhile after let's say bishop b3
knight knight to c5
um let's just play another move for
white
let's say knight to e6
now all of a sudden you can see
uh black can't immediately jump to this
square but black is always going to be
the one threatening to jump in with with
the knight meanwhile we're just we're
never really able to get this move
knight to d5 through
and in the long run black is going to
have very serious chances to
uh claim c5 or claim d4 as an outpost
maybe we'll even see bishop c5
uh these guys might get traded off and
then uh in the long run again
black's gonna come over and play knight
d4
and so these structures in general
uh tend to favor black because again in
chess pawns don't move backwards so this
c pawn can never kick out a knight that
lands on d4 meanwhile black still has
this nice c6 pawn that's preventing our
play on the queen side now the exception
to this because white does go for these
structures quite quite a lot uh is when
we can prevent this knight from getting
to e6 basically
um so often times you'll see this happen
let's say
just some nonsense moves let's say black
gives us like a free tempo here
if we can get some position where white
has played like c5 then you could very
seriously consider going for this
because you're preventing this move
knight c5 and you're making black's life
a little bit harder to actually achieve
this kind of 96kn84 type of position and
we're playing over over here a little
bit more quickly
but it's good to know that in general
statically the structure should favor
black and it's because of about the
central squares white just simply has no
control over d4 and black is fighting
back against their control over d5
um
so once again the the point i'm trying
to make here black is really really
hoping that white loses patience and
does something in the center you know
they they want us to blink first they
want us to give them the c5 square and
allow them to do this this kind of
maneuvering and play against the
weaknesses that are made when you push
all your pawns forward
uh so instead white should just stay
patient so what was our plan with h3
what did we want to do
bishop e3 that's right so that's what i
played here
uh and now we do actually reach this
point where black is almost entirely out
of useful things to do
you can argue that you could play the
move bishop f8 but we'll see black had
other ideas in mind for this bishop so
he's out of useful things to do so he's
the one who has to break the tension in
the center by taking on d4
so i will take back
and now obviously what is the big
difference between this structure and
the one that we were just looking at
there's something
very important that's that's way
different
um for black oh yeah i mean i mean they
have the c5
yeah okay so they have the c5 square
available but uh let's let's compare it
to this structure so so what's
difference between this structure and
after bishop e3
take take
yeah black c5 pawn is a d6 pawn so
that's going to change a lot number one
white still controls d4 which is a huge
huge advantage that means we're not
really worried about knight d4 from
black in fact we're the ones who are
occupying the center with our pieces
and on top of that black is left with
this
weak d-pawn on the half open d file
now what's the benefit for black well
black does get this c5 square that he so
desperately needs because he was low on
space had nothing to do with his pieces
and as pointed out yes the half open e
file is also there so black is gonna try
and get some counter pressure against
the the e4 pawn
so in the long run
what is is black really trying to do
here what is what is black's big idea to
to equalize
you know it's pretty far-fetched in this
position
but in your ideal world like play maybe
like five moves in a row for black
and you might have have something
what do you think sorry do you want to
does black one
d5
yeah in you know some like fairyland
world we want to play d5 um we're going
to play d5 we want to get rid of white's
extra central space and and just be be
totally equal
um barring that maybe you know black is
going to try to pressure e4 forces to
make a weakness and then maybe try to
play on the king's side somehow but the
thing about the old indian is the
black's pieces just aren't very well set
up for this in my opinion it's very hard
to sort of organize around this d6 pawn
like your queen on c7 can never really
get to the king's side as long as the
d-pawn is there
um and it's just gonna be very very
tough so
uh yeah maybe we can play for d5 maybe
we can actually play for for something
like b5 in this position which was
brought up a little bit earlier uh the
point sort of indirectly being if we can
get rid of the c pawn then maybe again
we can try to play d5 but
i'm very tough here for black to find
those active ideas
so uh instead practically what happens
is after knight to c5
um
black is is sort of just going to try to
organize his pieces a little bit get
them all in reasonable squares and then
just sort of wait for for white to to do
something and then try and
try and find some kind of counter punch
which which we'll look at
so after knight to c5 let me double
check myself here
yeah so i think this is the worst move i
played in the game
um
so let's just do some counting
knight to c5
my e4 pawn
is attacked twice
um giving another given another move
black might play bishop f8 and attack my
pawn a third time and given it you know
a fourth move maybe black can even try a
queen to e7 attacking my pawn a fourth
time you know kind of kind of scary
so in the short term i need to figure
out how am i going to defend the e pawn
uh
now the the way i chose in the game
maybe is not the most natural way to
organize the white pieces
but i'm curious if you guys can come up
with with how you would defend the e4
pawn in this position so
we we know sort of our opponent's next
move is probably bishop f8 and attacking
our e-pawn so how do we want to
anticipate this how do we want to get
ready for this this to come
we could also just ignore it until it
happens but then you know once it
happens we have to have something in
mind
so bishop f8 is the idea that i was
worried about
yeah brian
um
i'm thinking about it seems kind of
weird but i'm thinking about bishop f3
to
also
open up uh
open up the space for our rook to come
back to e1 maybe
yes so bishop f3 is one of the big ideas
that i was i was looking at definitely
um
there's a couple other ones that i want
to at least touch on before we get into
details so bishop f3 is maybe the
easiest solution you know it's one move
your pawn's defended again you don't
really have to worry about your pawn
um but what else is there someone in the
youtube chat mentioned the very
interesting idea of knight f5
um which might not work immediately but
is definitely good to keep your eye on
um sort of meeting the the play here
with play on d6
um does this actually
work i'm kind of curious
black might not be so unhappy about some
move like knight takes e4 here
and if you take me i'll take back and
maybe i'm i'm getting away with it
if you take here take here
check
take
take
and yeah maybe this does look look nice
for white but uh black has taken one of
your pawns
so you have to be careful with this
nine-to-five idea there are some tactics
there
um and then what else it might be kind
of an ugly move but what is
the most solid structure that white can
make here
yeah just pawn to f3 right um either
immediately or after bishop f8 we can
put the pawn on f3 but what is the big
downside to pawn to f3
why did i call this move ugly
yeah it opens up g3 and it actually
further weakens f4 as well it weakens
both of these dark squares so it's
pretty clear how it weakens g3 right you
know this pawn was defending g3 no it's
not how does it weaken f4 well it's a
lot harder to play a move like g3 if
your pawn's already on f3 compared to f2
right
so because now we're never really
playing g3 it's gonna be harder to
defend our f4 square as well
so in the game i was calculating lines
uh following f3 i was looking at knight
to h5
um and i didn't really love allowing
this knight into g3 and i was looking at
g4 here believe it or not
but when after knight two to g3 actually
does come
i couldn't really tell if i was actually
going to be trapping this knight or not
and i have to play some ugly move like
bishop to d3 to avoid this trade i just
didn't love it
um now it turns out that this was the
correct idea but there's actually an
improvement here so white can actually
play bishop f1 in this position of all
things and then after bishop f8
i can go f3
and now if you try knight to h5
who sees the idea here
why is this difference
after g4 knight g3
bishop
that's exactly right um the big idea is
that we can do a sneaky little reroute
with our bishop here over to g2 and then
black is just going to be in big trouble
this knight is is hard to to to save
like you can try like h5 but i'm not so
sure that it's it's really going to help
you i'm just not going to take
um i don't know if i want to go king h2
stepping on this diagonal but i can go
uh maybe queen f2 king f2 um
and even if you play h4 in the long run
this knight is going to be very very sad
on on the g3 square it's just going to
be totally trapped and i think white
should be able to pick it up somehow
let me double check make sure i'm not
like totally lying to you guys
yeah okay bishop f2 or queen f2 are both
good
and if h4
even yeah just just f4 here and like
this this knight is totally stuck you're
at least losing a pawn
and maybe more with with ideas like
knight f3 and knight h4
so turns out that this was the correct
idea now perhaps understandably i was a
little bit wary of this g4 idea you know
i felt like i had a pretty good grip on
things and i didn't really want to go
nuts on on the king side
but as someone in the chat pointed out
bishop f2 here is also perfectly
reasonable um this knight is going to
get to a square on f4 but it turns out
this is also a very reasonable way to
play
now in the game
i did actually go for bishop f3
but this is gonna be you know just a
little bit unnatural i don't think it's
a bad move by by any means white still
is significantly better
but uh the danger here is that uh
you know by defending this pawn with the
bishop you've sort of limited your
options your you know f3 is now illegal
and your bishop is actually really
useful
um on the queen side
as we'll see
in a little bit
uh so here black should still go for
this bishop f8 idea
uh and then white is actually going to
want to reroute the rooks like brian was
saying we can come into the center
and here once again black is sort of
running out of things things to do you
know you can play bishop e6 you can play
h6 maybe h5
uh maybe g6 but you're running out of
useful useful moves with black
and in the long run white is going to
push kind of everywhere slowly
um
but after bishop to f3 white or black
chose to play this move bishop b6
instead so sort of giving up on this
pressure on e4 plan now that i played
the slightly awkward move bishop f3
so
uh after bishop b6 my first question is
should we take this guy
and my next question is what are we
doing
sort of in in the long term what is our
plan you know we've talked about black's
plans what black is trying to do but
what is our active idea here what do we
want to play for
so let's start with question number one
do we want to take this this bishop
it's been offered
oh and hello to ty in the youtube chat
who i met at this tournament actually
ty says don't take the guy
and i won't tell you how good a chest
tie is
so what do we
think all in favor
all opposed
okay seems like the room is opposed so
why don't we want to take the guy
because ty said so
okay
yeah this is a beautiful piece right
this is a beautiful piece
um and in general going back
uh you don't want to trade pieces when
you have extra space
so right now this e6 square seems like a
pretty good spot for the bishop right
it's off the back rank the rooks are
connected and it's pressuring our c4
pawn
however there are a lot of black's
pieces that would love to use the e6
square he would love for the e file to
be open so he could attack the pawn he
would love for his knight to be on the
e6 square so we can target our weak dark
squares
um
and i guess that's all he would love on
the e6 square um so if we ever take this
guy um i think even just knight e6 is
probably the idea there might be some
kind of argument for fe 6 and playing
for d5 but i think 96
and
black's position is suddenly much easier
to play you take off a single minor
piece and black's position is going to
get easier just because
now he can do whatever he wants he has
all these light squares to play on all
these rerouting ideas uh with these two
knights now this bishop's out of the way
so when you have extra space don't trade
the pieces
uh so that being said our pawns attacked
we're not going to take the guy how do
we defend the pawn
just keep it simple
yeah b3
and don't be afraid to shout out an
answer by the way if you've got it it's
kind of hard to to see to call on hands
sometimes
so yeah b3 is great
uh just defends the structure and
prevents us from getting kind of clamped
down with a4 later on
black plays knight f to d7 here
so now it's time to figure out what what
are we actually doing with our lives you
know black is running out of ways to
sort of threaten our position
so what do we want to do in the long
term
how can we make progress here
and the fun part about this position is
that there are almost no wrong answers
if you see a plan it's probably a good
plan which is why this opening is kind
of suspect by black
yeah okay so black is you know this is
good to point out black is trying to
organize the pieces here this is
probably why black avoided playing
bishop f8 earlier in the long term he
wanted to come to f6 but
it's not so scary right like it doesn't
come with a threat it's just
he's struggling to find squares for all
these pieces so we have a little bit of
freedom here to kind of do whatever we
want black is many moves away from doing
anything that that could be considered
dangerous
yeah okay so you're going for play
against the d-pawn as one of the plans
so that that's one plan to look for
um
and just for some more context whenever
i say a plan so attacking d6 is a
long-term plan but oftentimes it also
involves a change in the structure
somehow so look for those ideas as well
for for other plans
so piling on top of what uh brian was
saying with bishop f4 um some people in
the youtube chat are also talking about
doubling the rooks in the d file and
this is like sort of all in line with
the the attacking the d-pawn plan which
i think is a good one
any other ideas
yeah what do you think
i mean
like
yes it's not so much about opening the a
files so how would you do that
what moves would open the a file
but
there are some problems right now yeah
so no long term a3 b4 is a great plan
and i actually sort of played for it in
the game uh however the idea is not so
much about opening the a file as it is
taking away more space from black on the
queen's side we want to control the c5
square we want to be able to threaten to
play b5 threaten to play c5 ourselves
and those changes and structures that
opening of the position
is eventually going to be good for white
again we have more space everywhere so
if we can open things up somehow it's
usually going to be good for us because
black's pieces are going to be clunky um
stuck where they are
so a3b4 great plan
again though it's less about opening the
a file more about taking away more
squares getting more space in these
different pawn breaks
so there's one more big idea that i at
least want to mention
um so we can play on the queen side with
a3 b4 we can play in the center by
doubling up and attacking the d-pawn
and our position is so good that maybe
we can even play on the king's side so
how would we play on the king's side
here
it's exactly right so something like
bishop b2 and f4
and then we'll decide later on if we
want to play f5 or e5
but again it's about taking away more
squares from black getting even more
space and sort of
tightening the uh the vise the vice grip
we have on the position
um so all of these i i think are great
i think white is probably going to be
doing better
then is probably gonna be doing well in
all of these plans
now i wasn't really in love with uh just
playing like rook d2 or bishop f4
because i felt like uh
okay i mean i can't say too much because
i think it is a good plan but i think
it might be a little bit overly
optimistic here like i think black might
be going for knight e5 and if we start
doubling up
uh bishop f6 i think black might just be
well positioned to to sort of handle
this plane maybe we even need to play
bishop e2 first
and rook d8 for example
and yeah we haven't really spoiled
anything but i'm not sure we're really
making much progress here you know black
is
well enough defended he's controlling
the square well enough
and uh
yeah i mean i'm not gonna lie i still
like white's position but it's uh i'm
not sure this is
uh the plan that is gonna give us give
us a bigger bigger advantage
so in the game i wanted to play for
a3b4 and as brian said i was
anticipating that this bishop was going
to come out to f6
so i started with this move rook a to c1
just
again i want to play a3 b4 not because
i'm interested in opening this up and
again trading pieces but because i want
to be able to push these pawns forward
take away more space play for some kind
of a pawn break
and i'm also of course anticipating my
opponent's sex move well sorry not that
move
but the move after which was bishop f6
looking to target some of these weak
dark squares just get everything
defended get my rook off that diagonal
life is good so he plays uh rook a to d8
now
again what's one of the problems with a3
b4 actually i did play a3 first so a3
bishop f6
and now what's stopping us from playing
b4 right away
if anything
yeah the c4 pawn is is going to be loose
so the tactics
you do have to calculate a little bit so
b4 attacks this knight
so how does black actually make use of
these weaknesses
so we want to find some way to move the
knight away with tempo that way white
doesn't have time to
deal with this well
yeah so we want to go to a6 it's better
to include this now you go to a6
both pawns are hanging here it's not a
big disaster for white we can play queen
to b3 we really need to play knight to
a2 if we really need to
obviously those moves i'm not thrilled
with you know i don't want to retreat my
knight and i don't really want to put
myself in this kind of self pin going on
over here
so
might as well defend the c4 pawn first
so we don't have to worry about that
so what's a really effective way to do
that
remember i wasn't really happy with this
bishop on f3 anyways i don't want to be
here yeah what do you think
yeah bishop back to e2 i want to get my
pawn structure fluid again notice by the
way this knight is nowhere to be found
on the king's side anymore there's no
knight h5 knight g3 coming in so i have
absolutely no qualms about playing f3
anymore you know i'm not worried at all
this knight is a million moves away from
getting back to those squares
uh and that's the kind of thing that
happens when you have less space you
know your pieces start stepping on each
other and ideas that maybe you had a
while ago now just aren't there because
your pieces are
so uh so clunky
so bishop back to e2 is my move
now my opponent is like terrified of
this b4 idea so much so that he plays
knight to a6 to try to stop it
um so he is just defending the b4 square
so now let's see if you guys are
familiar with
what is known as the tactic that's all
i'm gonna refer to it as so here i set
up the tactic
so whenever you have these kinds of
positions these
i don't know not quite mirazi bind but
these sort of hedgehog style structures
where white has this extra central space
and black has done c6d6 put the queen on
c7
um there is
the tactic that you have to look out for
so here i played queen b1
which does two things it prepares b4
and it threatens
the tactic
so my opponent
was not not alert enough to notice
the tactic and played knight to b6
which
does in fact hang
the tactic so uh what is
the tactic
white to move and win it's like more
than plus three
really really good position
and again it's one of those positions
where there's no wrong answers white can
do like normal moves and still be very
very winning because the position is
just very good but uh
we're looking for
the tactic
yeah brian
knight d5 the tactic we did it
bam oh my god i attacked all the pieces
hung my knight to three different you
know exchanges
but it's just totally totally winning
um so have you guys seen this before
have you seen this idea before
no that's okay that's totally fine to
event so this is i'm calling it the
tactic because it is
a very very common idea in these kinds
of structures whenever white has an e4
pawn and a c4 pawn against a d6 and a c6
pawn so it's going to show up in all
kinds of different
sicilians even where you might you know
you might not expect it with one c5 but
maybe an exchange happens here you get
knight takes c6b takes e6 you can end up
in the structure you can end up in the
structure like i said from hedgehogs
from e4e5 setups sometimes depending on
you know what kind of line black is
playing and of course from positions
like this so really useful idea to know
whenever these pieces are lined up like
this it looks like there's a lot of
clutter on the c file but a lot of the
time you are just able to play this
knight d5 move as as a sacrifice
so really great move this just kind of
wins the game on the spot so
let's go through the different captures
here um first of all what happens if
black moves away this one's really easy
the night hangs right queen was
defending the knight so you do have to
capture this knight what happens if you
take with the pawn trying to win a piece
yet
cd5 we hit the queen we hit the bishop
can't really solve all the problems here
i guess i want to try queen
e7 for lack of a better square
i can just take
take
maybe here i can even just take e6 and
take uh take b6 i can do a lot of things
i can leave pieces on the board
white is is just gonna be crushing maybe
even this move is
uh a little bit more
uh mean i don't know
very sad position for for for black
i'll keep it simple though let's just
take a look take take take take take and
this rook is attacked
and this is threatened and you've you've
lost the game
so c takes no good
uh what about knight
takes what are we planning here
no reason not to take with the c pawn we
want to open up exploit this pin down
the c file
now the pawn is pinned so black cannot
take back so we have to move this bishop
nowhere to go besides d7
and then let's just keep the moves
flowing
supernatural chests after knight d5 your
moves start to come a lot more easily
yeah do you takes c6 if you take with
the pawn there's a big big problem
so bishop takes but now of course we can
continue capturing
and black actually just loses a full
piece directly in this line
and this all pretty much happens by
force right
you know black could have gone to c8
instead and just not recaptured here
played like knight back to b8
uh you know insert your favorite joke
about setting up for the next game
uh but you know this is obviously
losing a million ways
um so knight takes no good which is why
in the game my opponent played bishop
takes
uh but here of course we are again
taking with the c pawn this is our whole
idea opening up the c file in dramatic
fashion
uh black tried this idea of c5 just
desperately trying to keep things closed
on the side of the board
and now again i mean there's a million
ways to win
this is actually not a threat yet but i
did decide to move the knight anyways f5
is just a really great square anyways
i'm not sad about moving my knight to
the f5 square
my opponent tried g6 so my knights
attacked i gave a check
uh and here my opponent was concerned
that after king to g7 knight to g4 was
gonna be winning which he was rightfully
concerned about that so he went king to
h8 instead
and now our next fun move how do we keep
uh how do we keep the the flow how do we
keep things flowing keep it moving on
the queen side we don't want to slow
down we don't want to give our opponent
a bunch of time to reorganize now that
we've sort of showed our hand
you know we've said sort of in in no
uncertain terms i'm opening up the queen
side i'm coming for you on this side of
the board and so we want to strike while
the iron's hot we don't want to wait
around let them slowly you know
reorganize bring these pieces back
we don't want any of that kind of stuff
going on
uh yeah bishop b5 doesn't spoil anything
at all um
it's not exactly opening things up but
you're sort of correctly
noting that maybe this rook is well
placed on e8 and you might want to like
push it away a little bit the only thing
i'd be worried about is maybe black is
starting to reorganize with knight to d7
you know i understand that this is like
pinning black's own pieces but he would
really love to to get these knights kind
of back in the game back towards like e5
things like that but this should be five
i mean white's white's winning white's
winning everywhere
but how do we open things we want to
open lines open diagonals
yeah pawn to b4 is excellent here you
know we've got this pin going on we've
got this diagonal that we want to open
up that c pawn is the last thing
standing in our way between uh between
these these pieces in glory so pawn to
b4 is is great
now tactically what's the justification
here uh takes
takes and obviously pawn takes pawn is
no good
and knight takes pawn is also no good
for the same reason we can sacrifice the
queen she can call it a sacrifice and
take on c7 winning a full piece
um so this position does happen i go b4
uh black does take with the a pawn
and then comes up with this move knight
to a4
so now we've done all the hard work and
you've sat there at the board you've
calculated and calculated and calculated
you found knight d5 you found all this
stuff
now
now it's fun because you get to
calculate some more but all of the lines
look really really good for you
so
how do you want to beat knight to a4
there's there's many many ways you can
do it
you know pick a move at random i promise
it's it's almost certainly going to be
winning
that being said though you mean your
opponent is trying to get you he is
trying to get you here
i'll even draw a third arrow for that
night fork
uh great wolf has some suspicious ideas
um e2 hangs with check in that line
great wolf
i think e2 hangs with czech
yeah queen to b3 i love it that's what i
played in the game
now if you
uh at home wanted to take on c5 great
job if you wanted to play b5 great job i
think all of those moves win
um
queen to b3 though is what i played and
i think it i don't know if it's best
it's it's winning enough very very
winning
so this knight's attacked it goes to b2
um this attacks your rook on d1
so jack what was the plan
this one
i'm sorry you said bishop e5 do you mean
bishop d4
b5 oh okay
bishop b5 i think is still good um but i
wasn't so happy about actually letting
this knight off the hook so so easily
it's kind of stuck here on b2 i wanted
to
i wanted to capture it
yeah rook d2 is great rook d2 is great
it's winning it's what i play
um the big downside is that oh no we we
lost our e4 pawn we're all so sad
uh so there's only one thing that you
kind of can't do here even though maybe
even you're still winning and that is
take on b2
because black had a trick he wants to
take on b4
and your pin is worthless because queen
takes there's night takes and here you
do get rook takes and again maybe you're
even still doing well but no need to
allow that kind of thing
so we just take off the knight first
takes
takes
and then i take the knight and black is
is just totally lost here
um special points at home if you
realized that bishop takes b2 is never a
threat because this is essentially
checkmate
um you just have to start throwing away
your pieces f6 is no good
because you still get checkmated
sad sad story
uh and rookie five obviously we're just
gonna take this rick for free no no
worries there
so bishop b2 never going to be a problem
which is why in the game black tried
rook to b8
uh now i just wanted to step out of this
i think so i played queen a2
black played queen e7
making a threat to take and take and
fork all my pieces so sad so i played
knight g4 just uh resolving the threat
bishop back to g7
and here i just played rook to b1
which is still totally winning
black tried h5 so i moved my knight away
black took on b4
i took back
takes
i just brought the knight into the game
bishop c3 was my opponent's idea uh so i
just offered a trade of the bishops here
i'm going quickly now because white's
just up a piece it's not not quite as
interesting
takes takes was played and then my
opponent i believe missed my idea
and played f6 which now it's just gonna
be force checkmate
um if he had played something like king
to g7 uh i think the easiest way to win
is to just go rook to c8
and the point now is that we're gonna go
check if you move the king
i checkmate you
if you play queen f6
i give check and take your queen
and if you play f6
um i actually do this really really mean
thing where i just come back to the c
file and there's not much you can do
about about rook to c7 uh in fact
there's
nothing you can do about rook to c7 this
queen cannot leave the seventh rank and
neither can the king kind of kind of a
sad situation here for black
and the game would just end but yeah
it's funny that neither of these pieces
can leave the seventh rank and you just
this happens by force there's nothing
you can do
sad sad times
um
and that's the whole game there you go
uh so my opponent played f6 i gave check
check and then he actually let me play
mate on the board doesn't happen often
and that is how you beat the old indian
defense
so this was sort of a long game um
hopefully the ideas in this opening
started to make a little bit more sense
it was i think the best game i played in
the tournament
um
and we we never really lost control
which is the big thing in this opening
because if you lose control at some
point if you start to do something like
going back for example
if here you you lose your patience and
you do take on e5 it's really easy for
the black pieces just sort of spring to
life out of nowhere you know suddenly
the the pieces all come into play
and black is is doing much better than
you might expect
so if there's one thing i can say about
this opening it's have patience you know
don't trade the pieces don't allow your
opponent to to get pieces off the board
and you're more often than not going to
be doing very very well
so any questions for me on on this
opening the old indian
yeah jay
a little ways forward from this position
yeah absolutely that's a great great
question so here i'm not gonna lie to
you guys i was kind of calculating
knight d5 on every turn uh because it's
even interesting here right i can play
knight d5 and it takes now i want to
take with the pawn and this bishop is
actually trapped
uh but i was here i was thinking maybe
bishop h3 is good right i'm giving the
piece back but sort of fracturing my
king side pawns
so with the queen in front of the rook
you know you would sort of expect that
this is even more powerful you know down
the c file but actually what it does is
it always gives black this nice tempo to
trade the queens
and after the queens get traded then
black again is going to have a free turn
to do whatever he wants with the bishop
and in this case give it back on h3 so
knight d5 doesn't lose uh with the queen
on c2 but this tactic is much much more
powerful if it is just the rook opposite
the opposite the queen so this queen
does a great job on b1 both defending my
my e pawn and supporting b4 and on top
of that it opens up the rook so that
this will be
a true tempo i'm winning a tempo by by
taking and opening up the c file
yeah great question
any other questions
we've got a just a couple minutes left
here
so anything at all or did it all just
make so much sense today
might have just made so much sense
all right well then i will do a brief
little recap and we'll take it from the
top and i'll ask you guys at the key
moments to shout out the moves so let's
go this is
varacobian style
so we have our opening so why not c4
here what does black have
e5 and this is a very very good end game
for black this is not what you want to
go for with white he tucks the king on
c7 your c4 pawn is misplaced
so we go knight f3
we develop the pieces normally
uh c6
and now this nice idea is what how do i
organize these pieces
yep we want to bring our rook here and
prepare for any opening of the d file so
queen c2 is a good start adding more
support here and opening up the d1
square
now what do we want to do with this
bishop
yeah we want to go to e3 but what's
stopping us
yeah knight g4 so how do we stop him
h3 wonderful so h3 here a5 now we don't
lose patience we continue with bishop e3
we get takes on e4
um how do you want to take back
okay
yeah so in the game i took with the
knight and kind of a funny story here i
actually thought for a few minutes over
which piece would be best to take with
in general the knight tends to be
correct in this position they're all
pretty good but the knight is the best
now why is that well you control all
these nice squares and you open up this
f3 idea so that's why we took with the
knight
knight c5
and how to continue here
got to defend e4 so what should we do
any of the ways is fine
yeah so i did bishop f3 as you might
remember however the best idea
surprisingly bishop f1 preparing f3 and
this weird g4 idea highlighting that the
knight is trapped so bishop f3 bishop to
e6 sort of a mistake by black
now how do we respond he's attacking our
pawn
yeah just b3 staying solid not trading
pieces
uh knight back to d7
played rook a to c1 not really a key
move
rook um a to d8 ignore the arrows so
what do we want to do here
yeah gain space on the queen side but
again any of the ideas are fine bishop
e2 f4 also still a great idea
um so i played a3 first going for a3 b4
gaining space we got bishop f6
bishop back to e2 understanding that
this bishop doesn't actually belong on
f3 belongs on e2 supporting our queen
side advance
knight to a6
and now how do we prepare
the tactic
queen b1 that's exactly right preparing
b4
um by the way if black doesn't hang
the tactic we do something just totally
awful like queen to b8 we are actually
going to play b4 it's not like a bluff
queen b1 i do want to play b4 and expand
over here on the queen side and this is
a good idea
securing a bigger advantage for white so
queen b1 but our opponent plays knight
b6 and what's the tactic
knight d5 winning the game but yeah you
had a question brian uh
yeah so i'm just wondering uh more
concretely how that
advantage would have um how you would
have capitalized on this queenside
advantage
yeah
so b4 ab4a b4 um and first and foremost
it's just highlighting that these two
knights are going to be much worse than
they otherwise would have been
um
but concretely i think you can play b5
almost right away
and the point is that if black takes
which black probably has to take
otherwise you
might just win this pawn on c6 so let's
let's put some moves on the board
i'm kind of curious what's happening
after knight e5 i think we will just go
b5
um so do we have an immediate threats uh
yeah we're threatening this knight
let's say black does take
now this is opening up the b5 square for
us to attack this pawn it opens up this
diagonal still
and you know we're we're just increasing
the pressure basically once we open
things up on the queen side then we
start to bring our pieces in that
direction and uh i think it's it's going
to be very strong let's let's check am i
lying
it's like plus two here um
and just to show you we're even
expanding on this side of the board
and
yeah the engine evaluation only only
grows here
it wants to play king h1 you don't have
to play king h1 everything is is just
going to be very very strong so we
expand on the queen slide we get new
squares for our pieces new ideas uh and
we just we keep on rolling even like g4
i think i'm at i imagine would be very
strong something like g3 bishop back to
f3 even
e5 ideas
just to put a move on the board if you
want to play something super super
simple rook to d2 okay you do have to
look out for d5 but it's still totally
totally winning for
white
black just has a tactic so defend the
tactic
and now i imagine these these kinds of
moves start to be very strong
yeah like knight a7 is
the best move and we really are just
piling up on on d6 now
let's see can i do even better here
yes i can i can just take
take
f4
and everything goes backwards everything
goes backwards
you just get all of all of the space all
of the space is the idea
okay
um okay but instead
we get the tactic knight d5
takes takes
and now it's it's very very sad for
black so
c5 happened we played uh our knight to
the king's side and check
and now how do we continue ripping open
the queen side files last question for
you guys
before
the end of the lecture
yes b4
at the very very end of the lecture
um and yeah again we're not going to let
black stop our ideas over here by
playing c5 we just continue opening up
diagonals opening up files and the rest
is going to be easy so
the tactics work out for us
we win all the material
dodge a couple remaining threats
bishop d2 and our opponent hangs
checkmate to end end the game
so we spent the whole hour on this game
i didn't really expect to do that i
thought i was gonna get to show more
games but that just means there's more
for next week i guess so thank you guys
very very much for joining me here
tonight uh be sure to stick around uh
grandmaster robert kungoski is gonna be
here with uh prepare like a pro i think
is the class no it's not it's
grandmaster's choice prepare like a pro
is on thursdays um so be sure to stick
around for that i love robert's lectures
i think they're super uh entertaining
and informative
and that's all for me tonight so once
again thank you all very much for
joining me as always my name is caleb
denby and i will see you next time
[Music]
you